[Music]
good morning
i'm wally gilbert and i'm going to talk
to you about
how i change from being a scientist to
an artist
i had a long career in science
as a professor at harvard and then in
biotechnology and for the last 20 years
i've been doing art
i began as a theoretical physicist of
the very mathematical kind
and i took my doctorate in cambridge in
england
and i was an assistant professor of
physics at harvard when i became
interested in molecular biology and
turned into an experimental laboratory
scientist i first worked on
very important problems in molecular
biology
the general problem of how does dna do
anything
i was on a team with jim watson that
discovered messenger rna
i discovered polyribosomes that make
proteins i discovered how the growing
protein chain was actually elongated
and then i worked on how dna was
controlled i isolated the first
repressor a control protein that turns
the gene off i isolated the dna region
that that protein bound to to control
the gene
and i worked out that first dna sequence
for that particular dna region 20 bases
long it's actually one of the first long
dna sequences that was done
and it took us two years
one base a month
and then in 1976
i discovered a rapid method to work out
dna sequence
one could do hundreds of bases in an
afternoon rather than one base a month
and that made it possible to work out
genes entirely fred sanger in england
worked out another method of similar
power at the same time
the world began to use these two methods
to sequence genes
ten years later by the middle eighties
eight million bases of dna had been
sequenced
my nobel prize in 1980
is the discovery of this fast dna
sequencing and fred sanger and i shared
the nobel prize
the three billion basis of the human
genome was first sequenced by 2000
taking about 10 years
so we had gone from impossible to being
able to completely sequence a human
being
and by now they're machines that can
sequence the human genome in 30 minutes
science is in general the effort to
discover new truths about the world
richard feynman once described the
excitement of discovery
as being that wonderful moment in which
you know something about the world that
no one else yet knows
it's a true true fact about scientific
discovery is very evanescent because the
moment you discover something you then
proceed to tell somebody else about it
as scientists we have the creative drive
to discover or to make something new
that's never been made before
but in science that new thing must be
true
that's a social construct and science is
a socially constructed
effort
the truth we find by experiment
an experiment means a process
that other scientists can repeat and
convince themselves of its
truth
or by mathematical proof that other
scientists agree is correct
and can follow and do the artist also
has the same creative drive to discover
to make something new not made before
but an art
we don't have a criterion of truth we
have a criterion of beauty
the social construct is other people
like the art and will buy it
nowadays i do art i began 20 years ago
when i discovered that i could make a
six foot image using a two megapixel
digital camera
at that time people would tell me oh i
can make a postcard size picture
but you really have to have high
resolution which didn't exist then in
order to make bigger pictures i
discovered this was not true
and you can make very effective large
pictures that carry an emotional impact
when i discovered this i said to myself
this is an art form
and i'm going to show you the sorts of
pictures i make and describe my changes
over the years you must visualize the
images i shall show you
as a three or six foot image as they are
in reality
unfortunately you're going to see them
these on the computer screen
and they're rather small if i were
speaking to you in a lecture hall you
would at least see large images
projected on the wall
as i said i began with a two megapixel
camera
and could make an image this image which
is six foot in size
of a
sailboat this image is actually taking
pictures actually taken in egypt another
picture is i call doors it's actually
taken in a
museum in spain i'm walking through
before any pictures have been hung on
the walls and i see this scene in three
doorways and simply snap a photograph
the picture of columns in berlin
in the first years this is around 2002 i
was taking pictures of fragments of the
world
and then i began to do a series of
photographs just of graffiti
paint that i found on buildings
and these are
graffiti in spain
i traveled in in
italy
and took pictures of marzipan candies
in taramina in sicily
this is a
totally
imitation tangerine it's actually a
candy tangerine everything is made of
sugar
and here is marzipan peaches
in late
around 19 2006
i was invited to come to poland and
photograph
in an old factory
and i did a series of images
paint uh grease on a metal surface
paper from a press
an old firebox
a rivet
these are i call wheels but they're
actually
templates for sand casting
a fragment of a machine
a fragment of bricks on a windowsill
and we went to warsaw
and did a insulation in the factory of
30 two by three foot images
and 26 8 foot by 12 foot hangings
this picture that i show you of bricks
was in fact one of those hangings
and there is pictures from the
exhibition
a very big hanging with a woman staring
at some other another image beneath it
there are people
wandering around staring at these big
hangings of the fragments of the
machines
hung up in a
old
factory setting which contained the
machines
continue photographing looking at little
elements of the world
a bicycle lock
fragment of a chain a fragment of a boat
seen against the sky
i was entranced by patterns
which give you a feeling of the material
and the object but as i said because
these are fragments of the world they
become essentially abstracts here's a
still life
actually in the orkney islands there's a
little scene of nature again from the
orkney islands
the scene of
two cheeses
in a market in poland
again the new york new islands
a picture i call not seaworthy
an ancient boat sort of falling apart
a picture that's actually in turkey
there's simply a still life of a
clothes on the line
in around 2008 i did photographs of
ballet dancers in rehearsal
and on the stage
and those pictures appeared in a book
called behind the scenes at boston
ballet
i found the ballet dancers beautiful to
photograph
and exciting is
when you have something like this a jump
another ballet dancer jumping
a scene from a valley called serenade
another scene from a
ballet russian ballet
a ballet dancer in
waiting and rehearsal
i love these pictures
but
and i said we made a book with a number
of these pictures in it but i couldn't
get permission to use some of the
pictures that i really enjoyed
and so this picture for example i could
not use the original and so i made a
totally abstract outline from it
one dancer throwing the other another in
the air
and so i spent some time playing just
with outlines of dancers
i made these abstract profiles
abstracting the image the photograph in
the computer
and then i took
just this image of a head
and took the outline of the head and
shrank it down over and over again to
produce an image i call vanishing and
the original image here
is about eight feet wide and ten feet
high
printed on canvas
once i made that image and stared at it
looking at the three dimensional quality
of the lines
i decided i was fascinated by the lines
and the textures and began to play with
them
here's an image i call four faces
based on the image i just showed you
and then by taking these black and white
images
and superimposing them and adding colors
in the computer
i could make images like this
and i began to play
with the textures that i was making in
the computer
producing image i call green fluttering
another one that i call sort of red
red triangles
i played with these images for about a
year
making
more and more combinations
and then realized that although i
enjoyed all these images they were all
based on a biological curve
the original outline of the head
and i began to wonder what would happen
if i just played with geometrical images
and began another year's experimentation
in just geometry
and here's one of the images
i take a square
superimpose it and over and over again
shrink it down to nothing and then
continue
those superpositions and this is even a
more profound
almost mandela like
uh construction
this is going down to the center of that
construction
and as you can see i was pursuing
images carrying them out to infinity
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas